[Music]
this cluster of islands looks exactly
like chester cheetah and every time i
see it i glance down at my fingertips
hoping they're covered in orange cheeto
dust i've been brand brainwashed
i know you can see underground but don't
ruin the surprise
spoiler snobs
prairie dog was way under that note i
haven't noticed ground mammals that flat
since the steamroller crew forgot to
remove the roadkill before paving
also steamrollers don't actually run on
steam anymore so they should really just
be called
rollers and i know that has nothing to
do with this but hi welcome to the
channel
i'm putting an orchestra together calm
down aang you just tooted a couple notes
on a kindergarten recorder it's hardly
an orchestra especially since these
furry critters have no instruments this
is more of a vocal ensemble a tone-deaf
furry vocal ensemble
i've been training my arrow off did ang
just do a near square by substituting
arrow for
ass does that even work i would think a
smart arrow like aang would be fine
dropping a square or two but maybe i'm
just the arrow hole here
aing just airbended himself to a
standing position instead of using his
own strength that's a quick trip to
muscle atrophy kid never skip leg day
aang
never skip leg day i don't see anything
wrong with having one of those
fruity beverages while we plan our
strategy i do
are those blades even washed as
impressive as this is there was no blade
wiping before he sheathed the sword so
those things have to be so nasty no
worries
i clean up easy first dick move by ang
here to assume it's the other guy's
fault and not even apologize or offer to
buy another drink
second if you know that you're the last
of your kind in a world at war between
elemental tribes wouldn't you want to
keep your air bending on the dl
are fruit pies an agricultural product
yes and they come from the land of
hostess ripened in the famous chemical
preservative fields and dipped in the
finest corn syrup
farm-to-table goodness at its best
you've made a lot of trips into the
desert
so apparently these dotted journeys are
his desert trips but why do they all
just stop out in the middle did you walk
back the exact way you went out what's
the point of that
also does this loop mean you walked a
purposeful circle i mean if you're
mapping it with any sort of accuracy you
would know you're doing it right quentin
tarantino's avatar the last airbender
so this spirit has attractive assistance
huh i think he means they look like
actual foxes saka
yes but you can see how that would be
confusing considering mr convenient
mapman did the universal sign for
sexiness easy with the wiggly woo-woo
fingers there buddy this is a kid's show
sound vendors shoot away from the bison
technically sand bending is a form of
earth bending but that sure did look
like air bending with that dirt devil
propulsion system
in fact according to the laws of physics
without outside air i'm not even sure
it's possible to blow yourself even
though i'm sure many have tried
there it is that's what it will sound
like when one of you spots it
i haven't even had a chance yet to
mention how toff may be one of the
greatest characters in the history of
animation her spirit her abilities her
sense of humor
sin off for the tough disrespecting
gravity in case you're wondering how
they did this the building is actually
filmed horizontally and then they turn
it in post so it looks like the fox is
running up the side pretty clever
actually
it's completely buried in fact one could
say it's
libraried based on the length and
location of this rope there are two
possibilities first that they just
happened to have a rope this long and
somehow securely fastened it to the very
center of the tower or that this library
had a climbing rope installed i'm not
saying either is impossible i'm just
saying they're both unlikely enough that
i'm willing to throw a sin
at it and let the comments fall where
they may i am one she tongue
he who knows ten thousand things know
what owls also is knowing ten thousand
things a lot that seems pretty easy i
mean i know the states that's like 50
things right there
probably at least 30 of the capitals
plus i have at least a dozen friends
with phone numbers and addresses my
vocabulary has a few words in it wait i
know at least the first 10 000 numbers
that does it right there
humans only bother learning things to
get the edge on other humans
or to find porn you forgot about the
porn if you're going to lie to an
all-knowing spirit being
you should at least put some effort into
it to be fair this all-knowing spirit
can only remember 10 000 things so
so you like flying this is about to get
very awkward if appa says no be careful
what you ask your animals they might
just tell you the truth and then you're
gonna feel like crap when you have to
ride him out of here or
if he happens to get stolen
[Music]
hey look at these weird lion turtle
things when a show knows enough about
its lord or drop some serious
foreshadowing at this point in the story
i
have to give it the praise it deserves i
mean not that i went ahead and watched
it already
the information on the fire nation
should be right up here i mean sure
there's a giant fire nation poster over
the door and some dragon type statues
but this place is huge
how did you know to head this direction
in the first place hello
little weird fox guy sean hannity we'll
wait for the next eclipse then we'll
invade the fire nation you'll wait for
an eclipse
i mean i'm no astronomy expert but isn't
that something that doesn't happen all
that much and won't you have to prepare
for that day
waiting for an eclipse seems to be a
pretty ridiculous strategy and sure he
comes back later to try and find out
when it might happen but right now he
seems perfectly content just waiting it
out
countless others before you have come
here seeking weapons or weaknesses or
battle strategies i mean if there have
been that many a lot of that falls on
you snooty hootie how many licks does it
take to get to the center of human
depravity anyway
why are we doing this i think the more
pertinent question is how are you doing
this toff is barely holding on to a
sinking tower and evil hedwig is
viciously tracking down your friends so
exactly how much time do you have to
check
every single day between now and sozin's
comment for an eclipse
i mean this date-checking montage alone
lasts a full minute so any attention the
show was trying to build his eclipse by
how stupid long this task would take you
it's just a few months away of course it
is also just to reiterate a few months
away at the very least is 90 days which
means you checked at least 90
individual days on this machine with
each check lasting about
a minute think about how they are about
to pretend like the frantic katara
escape the oppa bison napping in the top
tower strain have all been going on for
an
hour and a half while these two have
played planetary roulette
and tell me it doesn't deserve another
sin for that nonsense
i'm sorry alpha i mean he could have
just flown upwards so really the
kidnapping is kind of on him
at least i'll have one specimen to add
to my collection
boy guardians of geful here sure went
from helpful to hannibal real quick huh
your water bending won't do you much
good here
use your spit use your spit
this works i could spend an eternity in
here
as long as his definition of eternity is
the length of time between his last sip
of water and impending death he'll have
his wish granted
why are we wasting our time with the
dewey decimal system
when your system is so much easier that
quiz did you know that cinemasins has
two more channels
music video sims and tv synths if you
for whatever reason like our snarky
style you'll probably enjoy even more
ridiculous [ __ ] over there okay
that's it for now back to the outtakes
i know you can see underground but don't
ruin the surprise
that's how they get you they're under
the goddamn ground
[Music]
hello ice cream are you sure
ice cream now you sir
are you ready for the big time young mr
flanagan
do you think they've got info on the
fire nation a map maybe
if there's a place you gotta go i'm the
one you need to know
this is the library
come on eclipse
stop stop